ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi i
numeri che quindi siamo tornati i suoi
figli prima di quinci ai ragazzi volevo
ringraziarvi di cuore anche se l'ho già
fatto in tutti i modi possibili però
ieri quando me solo gravava 999 mila
iscritti oggi siamo oltre un milione
quindi grazie grazie grazie se non avete
ancora avuto abbastanza di grazie grazie
allo speciale un milione di iscritti il
primo speciale ne faccio 3 uscirà domani
quindi state tranquilli e non mi
tempestata di messaggi su quello perché
ve l'ho già detto quindi tranquilli è
che possiamo cominciare con è più
rispettata la scorsa settimana e non
l'ho fatto non so perché mi ha dato 48
quiz favi subito a caso cioè manco il
tempo di iniziare ho già letto per favia
caso ciao favi questo questo è per te
guarda non l'avrei mai detto giorno però
che ti piace ma avverto sarà molto
particolare
ok a parte gli accenti che sei
dimenticato ma non importa fa vj un
maschio o una femmina una femmina credo
per il treno che cazzo c'entra anche il
3 c'è anche la possibilità di scegliere
treno effettivamente l'ho chiamato ho
controllato non mi ricordo se era un
treno o meno però va bene la costiera un
treno perfetto mi piacevano i treni
veramente la risposta è bravo ma non ho
voglia di continuare quindi finisce qui
ragazzi il livello di happy meals più
bello che io abbia mai fatto
giuro faceva safety cube che mi sembra
carina è cosa vuol dire michele beh
ragazzi sono diventato un occhio
fantastico già una cosa stupenda lo
schiacciando ovviamente qualsiasi
meraviglioso ormone però in una fiera da
qualche parte divertente che ce n'è uno
shock che dorme ragazzi non lo sa che
non ho mai visto così figlio non ancora
capito qual è il senso di sta roba
perché c'è gente che continua ma quando
la fico quello cioè mi sono bloccato da
un metro non nuovi distranza ragazzi non
si muove più fantastico tra i due che
abbiamo imparato tutti il significato di
occhio non vede cuore non duole però
vabbè dai rapezzi non lo so è una cosa
no no vegan non sono uscite sono vivo
posso anche fare jogging sono
sopravvissuto ma le prove non si riesca
a sopravvivere bene madonna come lo
schivata la donna che però nello pupi dj
music mister che cazzo è stato dio lo sa
fare il dj ragazzi possa diventare un dj
solo morto ragazze restano i rischi del
mestiere un dj e soggetto a queste cose
hd extreme cos'è sarà bello bellissimo
ragazzo nave è stato è stato veramente
fantastico che a casa perché cos'è sarò
odio f sotto effetto di droghe star o no
vabbè chi ha creato stato livello era si
è fatto qualche canna o qualcosa cos'è
cioè è una roba tipo cosa ma sto gioco e
tipo botin botta simulator na roba
l'energia che cos'è sono stato appena
sparato da un fucile c'è max e poi mi è
rimasto solo il cuore fantastico c'è una
roba tipo
sì se mi chiede tempo basta ho vinto i
mondiali
ciao ragazzi voglio essere convocato per
la finale dei mondiali
che merita ho appena fatto un livello
che non mi so spiegare ma non importa
vabbè lasciamo perdere così cazzola
volato giù le gambe
ok church vabbè che cazzo di nome è
questo ragazzo un nome normale non
andava bene è una roba bello sono finito
ci sono montagne verdi in giro che bene
bellissimi cos'è due sono c'è un fan
tanto vedo sempre un faro non ho capito
perché i ragazzi dove sta andando
mi spiegate cosa 6 attento e non ho
fatto interna donna le scritte proprio
detenerla due secondi di più cos'è sta
roba
sono entrata un portale che figlio rega
voglio la porta di camera via la voglio
così dalle 6 avanti il look mi dispiace
ma devi morire è stato il portale a
scegliere il tuo destino mi dispiace
cosa c'è scritto non ho capito dove mi
porta sarò salve se tizio forze forse ho
trovato tuo fratello però non ne sono
sicuro nel dubbio vi presento non ho
nulla da insegnare la persona fragile
come tema a soreta ma che vuoi una roba
tipo
adesso alcuni poi mi spiega perchè sti
ci conosce il brest l'ing questa cosa la
sapevo mai così bravo che perfetto
ragazzo che e diventato un porno però va
beh ma seriamente non l'ho capito anche
marchi come cazzo sei pedalando zio
ormai ragazzi pedala pedalare è
diventato difficile non ho capito
neanche perché così ho preso sta roba
non ho capito bene dove come a sé apcom
ovviamente una scatola apre le porte
pezzo di merda ma già arrivano a testata
giorno è però è rotto i [ __ ]
[ __ ] sociale verso questa volta ho
vinto io ci mancherebbe cioè sono molto
26 volte almeno un tool se si vabbè ma
qualcuno mi cosa cosa ho appena giocato
la gara non ho capito niente
spongebob adventure no vabbè cos'è sta
roba regali alle 9 nei patrick e android
dovete d'onda non ho visto un caso devo
premere space perfetta da io sono sono
sforzi proprio che a 9 dai apartitica e
questo è stato uno dei più mi si è
incastrato al naso fantastico poi mi
dovete spiegare chi è che ha fatto
storia nel epicità assoluta suo livello
è una delle cose più [ __ ] che abbia mai
visto su giuro è arrivato al traguardo
che azzo nuovi ma si bloccano tutto
perfetto
non lo so neanche prima sarà bloccato
prima del traguardo non so perché a save
the child cos'è stata o dio devo sapere
devo salvare bambino devo uccidere non
c'è anche che fai per titoli e salvare
luke mamafunk uri amazon uk che mi sta
sul quello di più invece no ho fatto
crescere un pene a nonno cia che non si
sa come elan causato che dite già che
c'è altre spade madonna che mira lega
oggi
eccola colera per la macchina mi stava
sucuro la macchina se esco a prendere uk
anche se la vedo dura invece no una
donna che pervertito da schifo che sei
profit slow motion nova e basta cosa
voglio fare
non sa dare cazzo costo stimato anche il
melone ha schivato qualcosa non si sa
come ma la schivata anche luglio vi
chiamerò deve essere terminati con che
non avevo capito ma dall estero è uscita
la prima volta non cinesi nello stesso
vale mi dicono sì ma [ __ ]
cacciatore di anatre 9 per questa è una
figata lodo farlo trovo veramente
cacciare le anatre come nell'intento 64
da io stimo a vita chi ha fatto la roba
ma io devo schiacciarlo
l'ho preso l'ho pure grande e bella
soddisfazione riuscire a prendere le
anatre mi chiamavano c'è chi cazzo
non mancate si no come no regalone pozzi
e difficili è più difficile di quanto
pensassi muori stronzata cosa è
cazzo mi è appena passato davanti
dovrebbe essere un nuovo tipo di
pipistrello mim mondo sentire tipo e
lustro vestimento di batman credo sia
quello è fatto così come livello
stavolta ci sono livelli più epici del
solito non so perché l'uomo shaun save
cos'è sta roba nostri spiegate perchè i
sumeri bisogna salvare i meloni oppure
vetta salina il culo uno dei due dal
lancio ad devo lancia due lasciarmi
andare bello terminati non ci provo
eccolo lì mica bobba finito ho vinto una
radio rai molteni o da casa ping pong
devo farlo vinco io vinco io a
prescindere a me si fa no fermi nights
ma sicuramente giocato ho trovato la mia
ragione di vita voglio provarci sul
serio fermi da questa è una figata
pazzesca
c'è chi è chi si è inventato su diverse
del mondo campione del mondo ma devi
provare ragazzi qualche livello mio che
tra l'altro qua vedo che ci sono ne sono
usciti con dei livelli poi sei scarso
quindi non ci riuscirai a scherzo buona
fortuna e sarà meglio in tizio che ci ha
provato però non taccini non me ne sono
accorto che avevi la favolosa che si è
molto bravo negli in prossimo ma in
questo non ce la farai il set e malaga
ma non è possibile che aveva a fan culo
come si fa troppo alto nuovo figlio
sì so che posso fare che ce la posso
fare
caricarmi mi do solo con sé
denuncia facendo sono finito leggermente
male però vinto vj un miglior nokia che
ha fatto questo un milione gestito
milione ovunque bello cos'è sta roba
9 beh bello mamma proprio bello grazie
saluti la mater gratiae matteo bello c'è
proprio provincia in chi gli occhi
ragazzi proviamo a fare questo faceva
facciamo l'ultimo perché fa vice visto
che tu sei tu hai sempre odiato gli urti
carico questo livello premi il quadrato
rosso tre premi coloro che lo premere
sta roba
e stata un'esperienza adrenalinica
grazie per il livello amico mio tra
l'altro fuori j alena epica facciamo dai
facciamo l'ultimo questo perché questo
schifo è un'alternativa alla spazzatura
o cosa di cui ragazzi credo che fosse un
tunnel qui con perché non so se c'è una
finestra livello perché sono un ammasso
di gente a caso sembra un concerto di
justin bieber luca ragazzi concluso più
l'episodio spero vi sia piaciuto vi
ringrazio ancora per il milione di
iscritti
ringrazio ovviamente con lo speciale
perché spera di riuscire a farlo uscire
entro domani spero perché non ne sono
sicuro ma ce la metterò tutta e spero di
riuscirci i ragazzi sia il video è
piaciuto come società sul momento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non i video trovate nella descrizione a
cena se volessi dismettere lui ci
vediamo il prossimo film the le ragazze